the young faces peer out
this could be a school outing
but in fact these youngsters are now
refugees
they've crossed the border into poland
like thousands upon thousands of others
a wave of humanity fleeing ukraine
each bus that arrives sees a reunion
oksana that's her in the yellow hat
was here to greet her teenage son who
had had to travel all the way from kiev
we was just hugging and i feel my i
don't feel my body i just feel my soul
it's come to him
it was really
amazing because
so much crying and
now it's really happy feeling
this isn't just the story of ukrainians
though there are people in this center
from all over the world
some facing an uncertain
future woman lining up her children for
this photo is eight months pregnant
she's from uzbekistan and she doesn't
know where she's going to give birth
these men from morocco had spent the
past three years at students at
university in kharkiv they left when
they heard explosions they've spent days
travelling
we had have to
to keep survival ourselves warming
because it was very cold
so that's it and uh
we hope we are so thankful to get in
this
country that uh
take kick us in
in her arms
everyone is welcomed here but that early
sense of cheerful camaraderie feels like
it's fading as more people linger so
this looks more like a refugee camp
and it is full of people who had arduous
tiring journeys
genesis played football in ukraine he
fled with his dog zeus
we saw explosions overnight because we
wasn't killed
and
we knew we had to step out of cave to be
safe
how do you feel now
excited
i'm grateful
half a million people have already left
ukraine many more will follow
the joy of reunion only comes because of
the horror of war
adam parsons sky news on the poland
ukraine border